O.K., you need to see this really quick.
During the recent cease fire
between Israel and Hamas, Israel released
240 Palestinians from prison.
But this is what's crazy, that same week.
they also arrested 133 Palestinians.
This is what a lot of people
don't really understand
about the Israeli occupation.
Is that one of the most
egregious things that Israel does
is that they just arrest Palestinians
without charging them with a crime.
A lot of these
Palestinians are like teenage boys
who are arrested
for like effectively throwing stones,
Since the terrorist attack of October
7th, Israel has been going nuts
on arresting people in the West Bank,
which is different than Gaza,
where Hamas is.
They've detained over
3000 Palestinians in the West Bank,
which is ten times
the number of people
that they've released.
These people
don't know why they're arrested.
They will never have a trial, like,
this is not due process.
This is not the rule of law.
This is occupation. It's wrong.
Many of these kids
are going to be in prison
for months or years.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.